hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so in the last video that I did about
the Tesla battery about a month ago I
said that if it did well I'll do a
follow-up video on a new carbon dioxide
battery that was achieved by the
University of Illinois in this video
we'll take a look
[Music]
we've all heard of lithium-ion batteries
they're everywhere
from your laptop and phone to electric
cars and planes but the main issue of
them is their energy density there are
many characteristics of a battery that
matter energy density is one of them but
you want to be able to charge it rapidly
of course you want it to be last as long
as possible with a lot of consumer
electronics products we often change the
product before we change the battery
because we want a new generation of
whatever it is but when you move to
things like electric vehicles and for
grid scale storage even more then the
economics say that you know you really
need that battery to last a lot longer
than a couple of years and that's one of
the challenges that with rely on battery
space although great progress is being
made to improve this the question has to
be asked what if there was a more
energy-dense form of battery although
there's other interesting options being
developed lithium carbon dioxide
batteries are an interesting option
researchers at the University of
Illinois are the first to show that
lithium carbon dioxide batteries can be
designed to operate in a fully
rechargeable manner their prototype can
manage 500 consecutive charge and
discharge cycles lithium carbon dioxide
batteries are an attractive energy
storage system because they have a
specific energy density that's more than
seven times current batteries so
state-of-the-art current batteries would
be about 256 watt hours per kilogram but
these new lithium carbon dioxide
batteries can theoretically reach 1876
watt hours per kilogram that's seven
times more and that's the exciting part
about this it means that a battery can
theoretically be seven times lighter
while holding the same amount of energy
will be the same weight and size but
holds seven times more energy the former
is great for concepts like electric
aircraft while the latter is great for
electric cars and all electronic devices
the problem was until now scientists
haven't been able to develop a fully
rechargeable version this makes their
potential to store more energy virtually
useless
unfortunately lithium carbon dioxide
batteries destroy themselves during the
charging and discharging process but not
anymore
I'm insulate he Cochin associate
professor of mechanical and industrial
engineering at new I C's College of
Engineering speaks quote lithium carbon
dioxide batteries have been attractive
for a long time but in practice we have
been unable to get one that is truly
efficient until now end quote
traditionally when a lithium carbon
dioxide battery discharges it produces
lithium carbonate and carbon as a
by-product the lithium carbonate
recycles during the charge phase but the
carbon just accumulates in the catalyst
ultimately destroying the battery and
leading to failure omim continues quote
the accumulation of carbon not only
blocks the active sites of the catalyst
and prevents carbon dioxide diffusion
but also triggers electrolyte
decomposition in the charge state end
quote
this carbon buildup causes a battery of
this kind to destroy itself before 100
cycles are completed the new
breakthrough battery solves this and as
mentioned earlier pushes the number of
cycles up to 500 times a minute as
colleagues used new materials in their
experimentation these materials
encourage the thorough recycling of
lithium carbonate and carbon stopping
the carbon buildup problem quote our
unique combination of materials helps
make the first carbon neutral lithium
carbon dioxide battery with much more
efficiency and long-lasting life cycle
which will enable it to be used in
advanced energy storage systems and
quote several Giga tons of carbon
dioxide in US every year so that's a
really big number and we need to get rid
of this not only we can remediate carbon
dioxide we can also use it as a source
of the energy so I want to convert it to
some useful chemicals I don't want to
leave the issues for the next generation
I want to solve it here interestingly
computer modeling was used as part of
the research process theoretical
calculations we use to deduce a
mechanism for the reversible operation
of the battery
so this all does sound amazing but a
word of caution must be given you know
break through such as this are amazing
in reality but they usually require much
more development before they leave the
lab and become commercially viable that
being said this breakthrough does look
very promising and with an energy
density seven times that of a typical
battery lithium carbon dioxide batteries
could become a vital part of the battery
revolution in the 2020s
but for that we'll have to wait and see
so what do you guys think let me know in
the comments section below so quickly
just some housekeeping I've recently
come back from a trip from America
through a youtuber van and some business
meetings and that was cool but that's
also the reason why there's been a gap
in videos I didn't really get any time
to create some videos before I left but
now I'll be getting back to posting more
regularly soon also if you haven't
checked out mr. beasts efforts to plant
20 million trees it's awesome
he'd DM to me on Instagram asking if I'd
like to get involved so I'll leave some
links below so you can check it out a $1
donation plants one tree okay so thanks
for watching this has been to gogo and
you've been watching cold fusion don't
forget to check out the cold fusion
podcast and follow me on Instagram and
Twitter alright so I'll see you again
soon for the next video cheers guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]